a word and action
yeah all right
goodnight Merry Christmas Happy Holidays
Feliz Navidad huh yeah no no I was
thinking about it howdy yeah the
three-four defense is better than the
4-3 because of the outside linebackers
I'm not gonna explain this to you again
buddy
hey relax trying to get out of here
every one minute one minute three four
is better than the four three cuz of the
outside roamers Spencer awful big you
wouldn't be trying to steal nothing
would you the only thing I got in here
something to [ __ ] your sister with
that's nice talk of your ass happy
holidays
yeah no I'll be up in a minute yeah yeah
well the farmers done down here oh I'm
trying to leave you out with you those
pants are awful baggy you wouldn't be
sneaking anything out of here would you
yeah you know what I got in here your
wife you want to say hi to her you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's nice I'm not even
married that's nice yeah I don't care
what he says we're going out for beer
[ __ ] wait I get right back to you what
the hell's wrong with you try to [ __ ]
leave here pants are awful baggy you got
anything in there yeah my dick you want
to see it keep pushing me I got my eyes
on you all the time
jerk